it's going to be a bullpen day for aj
hinch and the tigers today tyler
alexander who gets the starting knot
here's right fielder mitch henniger
kicks and delivers swinging a drive deep
to left field haas going back to the
warning track looking up and goodbye
baseball way out of here to the left
mitch haniger with his 15th home run of
the season giving the mariners a very
quick one to nothing lead here in the
top of the first inning rbi number 39 on
the year with two away here's ty france
the one two one swinging a high fly ball
softly to right center cameron back now
in in a little more makes the easy grab
moving to right center france soft fly
ball out near the bottom of the first
inning one nothing seattle justice
sheffield on the mound today for the
mariners facing the tigers for the first
time in his career that brings up
jonathan scope i think he's been locked
in pretty good in the last few weeks
and he slams one to deep right field
that ball is
out of here
we are tied
this just shows the strength of jonathan
scope going out getting this pitch
shooting it the other way
and it's a few rows deep that was a
pretty good pitchers pitch
fastball on the outer half of the plate
scope finds the barrel
and finds the seats here's miguel
cabrera cabrera laces one down the left
field line
that's into the wing
cabrera will dig for second will trot in
there he's got himself a one out double
his fl 584th
of his major league career
2900 career hits now from miguel cabrera
time he gets a hit he seems like he's
setting a record or tying a record so a
runner in scoring position now for eric
hawes
swinging a miss
strikeout for justice today
and no surprise that the strikeout is on
the slider
again just buries it in the dirt there's
a sock paredes
to left field that'll get down
cabrera will score paredes has himself
an rbi single and he's giving the tigers
a 2-1 lead it's another slider that's
pretty much center-cut
he had a great approach to this ball
kept his front side in first rbi of the
year for paredes go to the second inning
murphy with a walk first walk given up
by alexander sears bowers just acquired
yesterday from the cleveland indians
powers picks up uh base hit in his first
at-bat as a mariner
murphy chugging on to third and he gets
in there
good start for jake bowers here's taylor
tremell
and he strikes him out swinging big out
right there much needed out he climbed
the ladder with the fastball and got him
to chase up in the zone one out away
from getting out of it donovan walton
the number nine hitter
he got him looking alexander strikes out
the final two hitters alexander works
out of a first and third one out jam we
go to the bottom of the second inning
one away jake rogers muscled up last
night
lift it to deep left field
that launch angle is back
whoa baby second in his many nights and
make it a 3-1 tigers lead
he got it in his happy zone that pitch
down and in is right in his wheelhouse
so one on four detroit that'll bring up
robbie grossman swung on and a shot to
third diving stop seeger from a knee
throws down to second in time to get
willy castro and what a play by kyle
seeger didn't have time to get up diving
stop to his left
robin grossman of a hit it's a fielder's
choice 5-4 two outs in a matter board
jonathan scope now batting swing and i
miss it a breaking ball for strike three
and that'll retire the side tigers pick
up another run on a home run by rogers
we go to the top of the third two out
base hit for kyle seeger and he'll go to
brian garcia in relief here in the third
first pitch swinging to left field ty
france
three tigers converge and it is goodrum
making a whale of a play to end the
inning that is so difficult
and yet he made it look so routine we
played three first time seattle's had
the lead off man aboard
really taken off and he is in there
easily with the back he's got tools
braley's able to advance to third base
on a deep fly to center field and the
battery's first baseman jake bowers
pitch on the way to bauer swung out a
little tapper along the first base line
picked up by the pitcher underhand toss
over to first base and it's in time to
get bowers and on the play fraley taking
off will score now the tigers three in
the mariners two as bowers picks up his
first rbi as a seattle mariner mariners
have the time run out at first base with
two outs deal one slap nice play by
paredes from his knees to get walton
that ball gets by him that might have
been an infield base hit yes fine play
by paredes a run for the mariners with
the bottom of the fourth inning runners
at the corners nobody out so this is a
great opportunity for the tigers to take
advantage the 2-2 to castro
lifted to left center field on the run
goes fraley he's got it
good room can jog home rogers is going
to try and advance and does so with a
head first slide
good base running all around
4-2 tigers and another one in scoring
position with the top of the order
coming up grossman up the middle that's
through rogers is hungry for home he's
there without a throw 5-2 detroit
aggressive baseball means taking risk
and once in a while you're going to lose
but robbie grossman because jake rogers
is that second base
he opens up a little bit of a hole and
roger's with happy feet now he's got
wings on those shoes flying around third
base you head to the fifth inning in
detroit five two tigers pitching change
we welcome jason foley he struck him out
save that baseball
that's his first at the major league
level good for jason foley
one away that brings up mitch haniger
hannah one for two with a home run back
in the first
another fastball down hannigar looking
for his second and he gets it mitch
haniger a multi-homer day in detroit he
goes deep out to left once again his
16th home run of the year and it's now
the tigers five and the mariners three
what an afternoon for mitch hanigaard
new pitcher for the mariners is going to
be anthony misevich and he's got to be
thrilled he is a detroit area kid the
misawa crowd
on hand
strike three call
everybody but the tigers happy about
that
the one out base runner on the base set
lineup turns over for robbie grossman
one for three for grossman
grossman lifts one to deep left field
fraley tracking it
and that ball is gone
another bomb for robbie grossman and the
tigers add on two more last night
hitting one left-handed today
right-handed it's a slider
and he goes out to get it third home run
of the day for the tigers
daz cameron at third base opportunity
for jake rogers to bring home a run
rogers drives one to deep center field
tramell turns and he'll try and chase it
down it's gonna bounce off the wall and
away from him rogers wants three he's
gonna get there and what a day for jake
rogers at the plate what a swing i'd say
this the change in his swing has just
been dramatic ray can extend through the
ball he does not pull off the ball he
doesn't have that high leg kick first
career triple for jake rogers we head to
the ninth pretty good outing for gregory
soto one pitch away from ending this
ball game and giving detroit a serious
win
got him with a called third tigers take
the series from seattle the offense kept
adding on runs all day and the bullpen
does a terrific job on a day the bullpen
had this game from inning number one